الصين تنهي صفر كورونا باعاده فتح حدودها
والغاء الزاميه الحجر الصحي للمسافرين
الوافدين من الخارج بعد ثلاث سنوات من
العزله عن العالم في وقت تواجه فيه موجه
وباقيه جديده من الفايروس الحواجز التي
كانت تفصل الرحلات الدوليه القادمه عن تلك
الداخليه في مطار بكين اختفت فضلا عن
الموظفين ببزات واقيه بعد تطبيق القرار
الصيني وبالتالي تشهد البلاد ارتفاعا
هائلا في الحركه على مواقع حجز الرحلات مع
تخطيط الصينيين للسفر الى الخارج
انها خطوه ضروريه على ما اعتقد اصبح كوفي
الطبيعيه الان وبعد هذه العقبه سيكون كل
شيء سلسا
وفي هونغ كون ايضا تم تخفيف القيود
الصارمه للتنقلي من الصين واليها وهناك
عائلات تنتظر بفارغ الصبر ان تلتقي مجددا
بمناسبه راس السنه الصينيه
لقد مررت ثلاث سنوات والان الحدود مفتوحه
بلا عوائق
في عدد المسافرين من الصين دفعت اكثر من
12 بلدا كان اخرها هولندا والبرتغال الى
فرض اختبارات الزاميهم عند الوصول ممدده
بكين بهذه القيود التي فرضت على مواطنها
واعتبرتها غير مقبوله هذا وقالت منظمه
الصحه العالميه ان البيانات الرسميه
للاصابات في الصين لا تعكس نطاق الفعل
لتفش المرض كما تشير التوقعات باحتمال ان
يتفاقما انتشار الوباء في الصين خلال فتره
عطله راس السنه الصينيه نهايه الشهر
الحالي حيث يسافر الملايين من سكان المدن
الكبرى التي سجلت فيها اصابات كثيره الى
الارياف لزياره الاهل الذين غالبا ما يكون
المسنين وفي حاله ضعف
رشا خياط العربيه